COLT MCANLIS: If you're a
developer who finds that
you're pushing the edges of
the web platform, you're
really butting up against what
is sort of available with our
tooling chain, and what the
web and the W3C, and the
specs, and the standards bodies
are exposing, and it's
hampering you from really
realizing the vision of what
you have for your product, you
should be at this conference.
Because we want to hear your
voice about what's going on in
your company and how we
can make it a reality.
This is going to be one of the
first times where we're trying
to get the managers and the
engineers who are writing the
Chrome code in the same room
with the people who are using
our platform.
And so it's really important
that developers actually show
up with a sense of what they
want to get out of that
conversation.
So come with your bug list.
Come with performance repos.
Come expecting that you can
sit down with the product
manager of Chrome and tell him
exactly what he's doing wrong
in his day to day
job and why that
matters to you as a developer.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
And at Chrome Dev Summit, I'm
going to be giving a talk
that's going to overview
everything you need to know to
become a performance ninja,
using Chrome dev tools for
your web applications.
Come find me.
I want to talk to you.
I want to hear about the
problems you're having with
performance and what I can
do to make your web
application a success.